matthieu delormeau refuse de participer
à une émission présentée par castaldi ou
bernard montiel non
non c'est faux c'est vrai c'était faux
c'est vrai c'est vrai tu es fort
et tu es mathieu dit la vérité
c'est pas non c'était souvent week end
c'est pas ça ces jeux non je me réserve
pour vous d'accord mais dit la vérité
les
ans mais non mais non mais ça me paraît
c'est bizarre non
le paraissait bizarre des détenus mais
je me suis dit bon thé animateurs tu
passes chroniqueur après si tu deviens
chroniqueur de chroniqueurs touami
chroniqueur du chroniqueur de
chroniqueurs rien ordonné la descente
aux enfers à la
casquette voilà animateurs mais c'est
comme ça c'était l'époque en jeu